We learned how to use free tools to
understand what people will search when
searching for a solution.
Now let's think about
the places either virtual or
physical that potential customers
will be exposed to your business.
These places are the path to get
your product to your customer.
We call them distribution channels.
For Coca-Cola, a distribution channel
can be a grocery store or a restaurant.
Usually for consumer packaged goods,
the distribution channel is wholesale,
retail, distributors,
e-commerce websites, things like that.
Now for your app, it'll probably be one
of the app stores, or a website, or
even a creative partnership
you can think of.
So on that note,
let's talk about partnerships.